mike d'antoni citing personal reasons
and that's all he would give on daniel
house he did say it was not coveted
related oh anthony davis on a beautiful
set up from rondo
together he just steps up pj tucker
starts to front rondo throws it up over
the top
just a beautiful pass right on the money
right over jeff green
and now lebron james on the floor
covington still grabbing at his jaw it
looks like up top for davis
the second time tonight two of seven
five points we talked about michael
porter junior the third scorer as
anthony davis oh my goodness rondo is
just putting on the show on
boy these two wow they've got 2.1
seconds remaining denver foul to give
jokic
trying to disrupt rondo he puts it in
here's davis 4-3 in the win oh it's good
anthony davis has won it for the lakers
anthony davis is going to send the
lakers to a 2-0
series lead
in the clutch delivers the bomb great
defense by the nuggets just outstanding
offense
by anthony davis
who's made back to back huge threes here
in this fourth quarter they confirmed
the basket game over great play card by
coach vogel what he did was he put the
screen on the big fella big fellas
aren't used to coming off the screen
playing defense that's why yokis did a
great job getting the hand up but that
was plumley's man coming off the screen
he's talked all year about them not
being able to protect big leads
like he would like them to
porter on the cut oh he's met at the rim
by davis
this lakers team oh my goodness this is
beautiful oh meet you at the summit my
friend goodness what a [ __ ]
block shots by the lakers
and that's their playoff average lakers
by one three and a half gone by second
quarter here in game three alley-oop to
davis raja ronda once again with a pass
from just inside half court
he starts him up
jay crowder with poor body position he
spins out no ball pressure on rondo
adebayo
pass inside through it behind robinson
james floats it up and anthony davis
with the one-handed tomahawk lakers go
up by three
[Applause]
a good pass and finish by anthony
davis and then
boom
running the floor up three and yes
you know we're able to
be entertained by the world's greatest
lebron gives it away sterling brown and
that is blocked by anthony davis on the
other end
i mean i'm all for trying did a good job
of recognizing that the laker bigs were
not in position to contest a shot a.d
the spin of the slam
anthony davis working it inside
anthony davis quit showing off
i mean if you miss you want to leave
time to be able to commit a foul and
lengthen the game schroeder going all
the way dishes a d
throws it down to tyler
no whistle though schroeder sets it up
drives makes plumley commit spots
anthony davis and
anthony davis glides in for the flush
they've got to get a little bit more
ball and body movement
jd
what a dish from schroeder and he threw
that one down with authority
notices the real the roll man right
there and
hands it off and anthony davis does the
rash flushes that we've got a two-point
king's lead
it's gonna be jokic
he looked to give it back to rivers now
dribbles it out compasso from downtown
davis miraculously with a closeout that
never seemed to end this is just
ridiculous defensively
over the last two years as the closest
offender that guy is number two in the
league there's a reason why
six foot ten long athletic and
unbelievable instincts look at the
ground covered the stretch out
[Music]
[Applause]
sons were pesky down the stretch
which was way too much a deep going for
more
nasty
[Applause]
and then this backwards alley-dunk and a
foul by devin booker
what else does this man have up his
sleeve today
i'm sure eight would like to have that
over again here's lebron and crowder was
right there for him he knew it was
coming
another laker turnover booker running
the floor a little sidestep oh denied
off the glass
well you don't give up on the play i
mean it's this you know game three he's
riding that gold medal shine still
that's what it is
a little contact no call as payne tried
to draw the foul baseball davis oh
catching bodies in the preseason
18. express yourself
well mark jackson maybe
anthony davis
did hit the switch
a little bit early
[Music]
and from the rest of players it really
has improved his game rondo davis
appointment the ladder
and with a nice dropping of the anvil
puts it down he got high with a great
feed punch how about this just throw it
high and let the athleticism of deep
loony and james
intercepted by jordan ahead to beige
more tailed by curry lost by james off
to davis down it goes laker transition
it's all about transition for us i don't
care about our age we have enough
players to get out and finish at the rim
down goes russ slipped on the floor then
throws it away
take it by melt he goes one on two
didn't wait for anybody not tonight said
a.d right thing by trying to flush it
but anthony davis just made a better
play on the defensive side and gets the
block without committing the foul
west brook alley
davis and the foul
perfectly executed and a chance for a
three-point play anthony davis ability
to catch and finish look at the traffic
has two guys trying to close the
airspace he catches it delivery on point
recognizes where the rim is takes the
contact and finishes
just need to stop here cutting him
blocked by davis they still have time
though seven on the clock cutting him
all the way
[Applause]
on a consistent basis here the gem shots
first anthony davis says no i don't
think so
sorry i'll take it to the rack and see
if i can get a layup no i don't think so
now it's a b
with metoo in front of him look at this
spin by davis
reverse layup
show me some footwork anthony davis cd
just faces up did a dribble drop step
underneath
that's just a beautiful looking play by
anthony davis last we saw a d he went
seven for 17.
80 on the year 19
[Applause]
by anthony davis
christian thompson going up the flush
gets met at the top look at that right
at the middle at the top
in between two hands you'll see a sunday
when detroit is here at 6
30.
on the way a.d challenge get that out of
here
they keep challenging him and he keeps
going straight up and really